Musik So, hallo und herzlich willkommen zu dieser fantastischen neuen Ausgabe von Das Podcast-Ufo-Podcast-Projekt mit Trevor Dütter. Podcast-Ufo und Florentin Villnurek-Will. Natürlich, vielen, vielen Dank. Und heute tatsächlich ein Zweigespann, das uns in diese Folge hinein begleitet. Es sind Esther und Justus und die beiden sind Zwillinge. Nein! Ja, ich weiss nicht, ob man es gehört gehört hat. Ich weiß nicht, wie genau das dann abläuft in so einem Geschwisterpaar. Der eine spielt links, der andere spielt rechts die Tasten. Genau, es ist natürlich blöd, wenn du eineige Zwillinge hast, die beide Bassisten sind. Sorry. 30 Sekunden gedauert. Jetzt haben wir es weg. Jetzt haben wir es weg. Die Mail ist gekommen. Es ist auf Mute gedrückt. Hast du auch auf Mute gedrückt? Habe ich auch. Wir haben Ruhe Die Versicherung weiss mittlerweile, wann wir aufnehmen und sagt immer, Herr Will, da stehen noch Beiträge aus. Immer genau zu dem Moment und dann wissen die, okay, so passt's. Aber ist natürlich blöd, wenn du zwei Kinder hast und beide sind Bassisten, weil natürlich die ersten Bandkollegen sind immer die Geschwister. Die ersten Bandkollegen sind immer die Geschwister. Wenn du ein Kind bist und eine Band aufmachen willst, dann brauchst du deine kleine Schwester mit ihrer Triangel, den Bruder mit der Fisher-Price-Lenkradmaschine, die hupt, wenn man nach links dreht und macht, wenn man nach rechts dreht. Das ist im weitesten Sinne Perkussion und dann macht man seine erste Band auf. Justus und Esther haben das wahrscheinlich bis ins hohe Jugendalter reingetragen. Glaubst du, du könntest anhand des Intros feststellen, wie alt jemand ist? Nein, keine Chance. Ist das keine Gameshow für dich auf RTL 2? Keine Chance, es ist super schwierig, klar, bei Metal und sowas. Ne, auch da nicht. Auch da nicht? Nee, ich glaube, Musik und Alter haben gar keine Überlappung.
Okay, also das wäre wirklich die schwerste Herausforderung für eine Gruppe Promis zwischen drei und fünf, die etwas angeheitert aus dem Backstage auf die Bühne. Promis zwischen drei und fünf. Man ist niemandem zwischen drei und fünf ein Promi. Es ist das Baby aus dem Nirvana-Cover. Würde ich nicht sagen. Heute gibt es schon viele Kinder-Instagram-Influencer-Stars, was wir auch mal wirklich kritisch begleiten sollten. Stefan? Ich finde, man sollte Babys in die Kamera halten. Zeigt Babys in die Kamera. Sie sehen genauso aus wie alle anderen Babys. Oh, wer hätte es gedacht? Keine Distinktive-Merkmale und auch keine Erinnerung daran. Also du sagst, lieber Kleinkinder in die Kamera halten, weil die kann man noch nicht auseinanderhalten. Jetzt definiere Kleinkinder. Ich würde sagen Babys. Haut Babys in die Kamera, halt den Handy in die Fresse. Okay. In ihre knuffige Babyfresse. Weil die, dann kriegt man sozusagen raus, dann hat der Instagram-Account Erfolg und dann, wenn sich die ersten Gesichtszüge entwickeln, das schmitzige Lächeln, die Rosenwangen. Ja, die, so dann weg, weil dann sind das zu krasser. Das Horn, ja, die Hornschicht, die sich langsam über die Stirn legt. Ja, Hellboy-mäßig. Genau, es ist kein spitzes Horn, es ist eher so ein ganz breiter Fingernagel. Ah, über diesen Dinosaurier, die sich die Köpfluss, um Fragen zu. Genau, zur Begrüssung.
Inzwischen denkt man auf Begrüssung. Das ist der aktuelle Stand der Wissenschaft, dass sich Dinosaurier, die haben diese langen Schwänze gebraucht, um zur Begrüssung so Snipp, Snap, Snoop, sich so links, rechts, links zu begrüssen. Und andere Wissenschaftler reagierten darauf mit einem Wirklich? Mit einem hm.
Und dann der Dino mit dem grossen Horn, der Hornkappe, wo man dachte, ah, die sind einfach wahrscheinlich so aus 100 Metern aufeinander zugerannt und der, der übrig bleibt, so Thjost-mässig, gewinnt dann das Weibchen. Nee, die haben sich einfach, es hat sich gebildet, weil die sich beim Verbeugen, weil das sind ja höfliche Dinos gewesen, beim Verbeugen, bei der Begrüssung immer den Kopf gestossen haben, weil die sich nie auf eine seite geeinigt haben es war super eng in der u-bahn man weiss nicht a tür geht auf man muss jeden einzelnen begrüssen also das ding ist ja du hast ja wenn europäischen zum beispiel eine frau begrüsst ältere semester machen das noch bin ich befordert mit die rechts links rechts küsst sich so ein wang undurs auf die wange hauchen kennst du das ja stefan ich lebe schon auch auf demselben planeten wie du ne also klar ich mag vielleicht ein bisschen lieber videospiele als du aber ich bin schon teil dieser gesellschaft ne also wirklich nachzufragen hast du schon kennst du das wenn man sich so küsschenst du eigentlich, wie ich lebe? Ich wäre wie so ein Maulwurfmensch in so einem unterirdischen und dann einfach nur einmal in der Woche für den Podcast komme ich aus meinem Loch raus. Die letzten drei und achzig Folgen hast du mehr oder weniger genau das gesagt und propagiert. Und nee, ich war mir schon klar, dass du das wahrscheinlich kennst. Ich weiß nicht, ob du die Erfahrung schon mal gemacht hast, weil macht ja unsere Generation tatsächlich niemand mehr. Ironisch halt, ne? Genau, und dann muss man sich natürlich, das ist natürlich gefährlich, weil wenn sich beide für rechts entscheiden, deswegen ist klar rechts, links, rechts oder rechts, links. Ja, ja, aber wessen rechts, links, rechts, das ist immer das Ding. Naja, ich. Ach so, du. Ich rechts. Okay. Und du rechts. Bühnenrechts, ja, ich bin ja, ich komme ja von der Bühne, da ist das alles ein bisschen schwierig. Ich meine, die Dinos haben sich wahrscheinlich nicht geeinigt und dann sind sie mitzudem bestossen. Und daher kommen dann die Hornhautplatten, denn nur die haben überlebt. Die konnten die Vorpflanzen. Die anderen waren einfach schon früh morgens schon so Matsch, dass sie im Büro kaum noch was leisten konnten, gefeuert wurden und leider verarmt, verhungert sind. Das ist leider bittere Realität. Der Meinung nach von den führenden Paläontologen war es eine einzige Person. Stefan Thieser, warum hat ein Stefan Thieser eigentlich so einen grossen Mund und kann so viel Wasser pro Sekunde? Wie viel Liter schaffst du so pro Minute? Zwanzig. Ich habe zwanzig Liter pro Sekunde. Okay. Pro Minute. Wow. Nicht schlecht. Ich kann sehr schnell sehr gut laut trinken auch. Ich bin wie so ein, ich kann sogar, weil ich zu faul bin, wenn ich nachts zum Beispiel zur Wasserflasche greife. Bin ich zu faul, meinen Kopf aufzurichten oder mich so aufzurichten mit dem Ellenbogen, die so nach hinten robben, um dann aufrecht zu sitzen und dann das zu nehmen und zu trinken, wie normaler Mensch, nein, ich möchte nämlich so liegen bleiben, an die Decke guckend, in der Horizontale, nimm dann die Wasserflasche, setz sie langsam an und mach dann den Wasserspender, den man aus dem Büro kennt, weißt du, wo man dann die Wasserflasche steht wirklich, genau vertikal über mir und so kann ich trinken. Du musst dann ganz viel Sauerstoff von rechts und links holen und dann kann ich wirklich so eine Minute verharren. Die Schwerkraft macht die ganze Arbeit. Die Schwerkraft macht nicht viel Arbeit. Und du packst nicht mal mit an. Die Schwerkraft ein Karton dem anderen schleppen die die Treppe runter und du packst nicht einmal mit an. Du sagst, komm gleich, ich muss noch kurz die Handschuhe aus der Werkstatt holen. Bei der Schwerkraft muss man nicht anpacken. Ich dachte jetzt, du liegst sogar auf der Seite und führst die Flasche seitlich an deinen Mund. Und dann hoch. Und dann schlürfst du das, um deinen Kopf überhaupt nicht bewegen zu müssen, schlürfst du das so raus. Kopf wird nicht bewegt, Kopf wird minimal bewegt. Weil du so müde bist, oder? Du bist dann so richtig müde. Wann immer aber müde. So richtig müde. Und dann, wenn du getrunken hast, dann kuschelst du dich wieder so ein bisschen ein und dann geht's weiter. Dann geht's wieder schön zurück in die Schlummerwelt. Ich hab jetzt angefangen, kein Shirt mehr zu tragen beim Schlafen. Ist das der Klimawandel, der um sich greift, der die ersten Sexopfer sucht? Stefan wird sexy, es wird nicht nur heisser von der Temperatur, sondern auch ein bisschen pikanter. Weil es so warm war und ich gemerkt habe, war es eigentlich ganz cool, man hat wenig, dann bilden sich nicht diese kleinen Knubbel, Textilknubbel am Körperchen und das ist natürlich eigentlich sehr bequem Und dann, was ich auch jetzt verloren habe auf diesem Weg ist, und da müsste mir jetzt helfen, weil ich weiss, dass ich da auf dem Irrweg bin, aber mir fallen selber nicht genug Gründe, das nicht so zu machen, weil man kann meine Bettdecke, die ist sehr cool, die ist sehr dünn und die kann man, die die kühlt auch cool. Und die kann man waschen, weil die ist so dünn. Und so sehr, kann man sehr klein machen. Kann man nicht Waschmaschine packen einfach. Und da habe ich jetzt den Bettbezug weggelassen. Uh, okay. Weil der ist eh immer, der verrutscht, Bettbezüge sind so eine Scheisse. Die verrutschen immer, dann hast du irgendwann nur diese Bettbezug, dann ist die ganze Innendecke so nach hinten in eine Seite gerutscht und dann ... Ich glaube, du gehst hier einen Schritt zu weit. Der Normale Zustand ist, es gibt zwei Schichten zwischen deinem Enkelkörper und dem zu bewahrenden Bettdecken, Heiligen quasi. Dazwischen gibt es zwei Schichten, Bettbezug und deine Kleidung. Und du hast jetzt quasi schlagartig beide Epidermis, einfach Cut the Middle Man, beide einfach rausgenommen und jetzt wirklich direkt. Das ist mir zu intim, das ist zu intim. Aber nenn mir einen Grund und ich hatte neulich wirklich das fantastische Bett der Welt. Ich hatte wirklich das perfekte Bett mit einer Bettdecke, die nicht verrutscht. Aber ich musste reingucken, ich musste reinschauen, was da in sich vorsichtig ist. Du konntest nicht schlafen, du dachtest dir, jetzt fühl erst mal nach, fühl erst mal nach, bevor du reinschaust, Stefan. Ja, ich habe aufgeregt, habe das Licht angemacht, habe den Sipper gesucht, reingeguckt und dann gesehen, genial, die ist verknotet. Die Innendecke ist mit dem Bettbezug verknotet. Das ist wirklich, und das an sechs Stellen. Fantastisch. Ich bin gerade in so einem Bettdeckentunnel. Es freut mich, dass die Menschheit noch Fortschritte macht. Ich dachte eigentlich nach der Playstation 2, okay, jetzt ist Schluss. Fotorealismus. Fotorealismus, besser wird es nicht, es wird nie eine 3 eine drei geben aber jetzt sagst du mir okay es gibt eine knoten technologie sehr früh aufgegeben an die menschheit zu glauben was für ein pessimistisches welt geht es da geht noch mehr aber der zwei war ich schon völlig zufrieden das konzept zahlen sollte dir schon hoffnung machen also wenn du sagst beide als zwei das nicht gehen also selbst wenn grosse Fortschritte macht, wahrscheinlich kommt noch eine drei. Also da hätte ich dir zugerufen. Diese Hoffnung ist gefährlich, mein Freund. Ich warte immer noch auf The Lego Movie 3, kommt nicht. Manchmal ist nach zwei auch Schluss. Das stimmt, das stimmt. Aber ich finde es pervers, was du machst, tatsächlich deinen eklhaften Körper direkt in die Bettdecke zu reiben. Man ist nicht ekligkelig je mehr schichten du auf dir hast desto ekliger wird es doch und schwitzt doch alles voll man verliert irgendwie tausend liter irgendwie so eine absurde hohe zahl ja aber das saugt ja weil das saugt ja sich wieder ein und mein kopf ist es saugt sich wieder so ein geblieben sehr viel wasser irgendwas zwischen zwei und zwölf litern der körper weiß er will, ne? Schwitz, schwitz, schwitz und dann wache ich auf, weil ich Durst habe. Ja, genau. Und man sich auch denkt, ja, merkst du selber gerade, oder? Ja, und ich muss mit mir aufs Klo. Können wir darüber reden, dass das Wasser immer falsch gelagert ist? Dass da auch einfach, glaube ich, intern nicht gut kommuniziert wird. Nein. Mit Leuten, raus, raus, raus, das Wasser und eine andere Abteilung, wann kommt denn Neues? Moment mal, Gero, hä? Weil gerade hat doch die Urinabteilung gesagt, dass es noch okay ist und wir noch einfach mehr Wasser brauchen und wir eher dehydriert sind. Wasser brauchen? Wir hauen hier seit Wochen Wasser raus? Hä? Ich sag ihm seit Tagen, seit Nächten, dass er Durst hat und er hat schon wieder die Technik angewandt, wie er wie ein Wasserspender im Büro sich zehn Liter reinbaut in der Minute. Mein Chef hat es mir erklärt, wir müssen Wasser durch die Haut, durch die Hautporen nach außen drücken, damit, so und jetzt, warte, warte, warte, gleich kommt es. Ich habe es schon mal gehört. Es hat was mit Kühlung zu tun. Das, warte, die, das, wenn die Bettwäsche, wenn die feucht ist, dann kühlt die uns zurück. Ah, okay. Weil eigentlich wärmt die uns. Eigentlich wärmen wir die, aber ... Hallo, hi. Ich bin eine Synapse von oben. Hallo. Hallo. Na, meldet ihr euch auch mal wieder? Ich habe in einer Doku gesehen, dass zu viel Wasser töte. Ciao. Ich bin raus. Ciao. Und so werden viele Informationen verarbeitet. Die sind die schnellsten im ganzen Körper, trotzdem so ganz. Hallo. Manchmal muss man auch gegen die Erwartungen casten. Eben. Ja, absolut. Gegen die Erwartungen. Es ist nicht alles so leicht. Nee, aber jetzt bin ich in so einem, weil man schläft, glaube ich, ein verschläften Drittel seines Lebens. Wir kennen die Zahl. Ich finde die Aussage Verschlafen, finde ich albern. Man könnte ja auch sagen, du vermisst zwei Drittel deines Schlafs. Also du kannst ja auch andersrum aufziehen. Bislang vermisse ich ein Drittel meines Lebens. Zwei Drittel deines Lebens schläfst du nicht. Was ist da los? Warum schläfst du nicht mehr, anstatt zu sagen, man verschläft? Wer hat eigentlich diesem Wachbewusstsein so viel Autorität gegeben? Nach die Nachtschicht denkt sich, Leute, wir räumen hier immer auf, wir machen alles, wir brauchen immer ein bisschen mehr Zeit und die Tagschicht, uh, Tagtraum, uh, hast du eine Ahnung, was so fucking Albtraum ist? Die machen geilen Scheiss, okay? Die produzieren die richtig guten Sachen. Nee, aber Traum ist wahnsinnig gut konnotiert. So, ah, ich hab was geträumt, ah, was denn, erzähl, erzähl uns alles. Und dann trinken die dabei einen abholen Spritz und erzählen uns ihre Träume. Oder dann wiederum auf der Gegenseite der Tagtraum eher so, so ein Tagträumer. Ja, oh, du bist ein Träumer, du hast deinen Kopf in den Wolken. Da ist aber dann der Tag wiederum auf der Gegenseite der Tagtraum eher so ein Tagträumer. Ja, du bist ein Träumer, du hast deinen Kopf in den Wolken. Da ist aber dann der Tag wiederum auch wichtiger konnotiert, weil wenn man den Tag verträumt, geht man als Tagträumer, als Stoffel. Die Nachtträumen kannst du verträumen, scheißegal. Ja, also ich jedenfalls verschwende ein Drittel meines Lebens mit Schlafen, mit diesem unnützten Schlafen. Vielleicht nicht mehr, denn es gibt viele neue Technologien, die es einem ermöglichen, die Nacht besser zu nutzen. Hoffe ich zumindest, weil letzten Endes wir schlafen sehr viel und ich wollte immer schon abnehmen in der Nacht, Spanisch lernen in der Nacht, Abitur nachholen in der Nacht, Astrophysik. Da hast du so Seile an den Handgelenken und die zerren dich immer so hoch und runter, während du schläfst.
Schlank im Schlaf.
Schlank im Schlaf. Schlank im Schlaf und dann wachst du morgens auf, Muskelkater, aber hast schon mal ein Workout hinter dir. Ja, auf jeden Fall, die ganze Nacht. Wann trainierst du eigentlich? Sag mal, wann trainierst du eigentlich, Mirko? Ich trainiere immer zwischen zwei und fünf Uhr morgens. Aber das ist doch mitten in der Nacht. Ja, aber da schlafe ich, ich krieg's gar nicht mit. Aber wie kriegst du das hin? Naja, also ich turniere im Schlaf. Aber wer? Okay, Leute, könnt ihr ein bisschen... Ich kann noch mehr Werbung machen als du. Okay, hä, wieso? Aber wir sind doch gerade bei QVC. Also es ist eine Werbesendung und nicht ein Infomercial. Ja, aber ihr müsst es ja nicht komplett übertreiben. Ihr seid ja immer noch normale Menschen, die reden, ihr schlackert mit den Armen, ihr werft den Kopf hin und her.
Wir wollen das verkaufen, schlag im Schlaf.
Ja, aber es ist einfach ein bisschen irritierend.
Okay, dann geben wir uns noch mal ein Zeichen.
Okay, sag mal, wann trainierst du eigentlich, Mirko?
Mitten in der Nacht.
Hast du schon mal was gekauft bei QVC?
Hat sich schon mal verschlagen? Nee, ich habe super die Angst, dass meine Mom in das Alter kommt, wo sie das jetzt guckt oder so. Ist noch nicht passiert. Ist ja auch nicht der Typ für, aber ich habe Angst, dass es passiert. Wenn du zum ersten Mal was da kaufst. Weil meine Grosseltern kamen irgendwann in dieses, ja was macht man jetzt noch mit unserem Leben? Wir werden künstlich im Leben erhalten vom Gesundheitssystem. Uns geht es beiden nicht mehr so gut, aber das Gesundheitssystem sagt bleibt hier bleibt hier nimm den roboterarm hier schnell du kriegst ein roboterohr wir brauchen dich noch und dann sitzt deine cyberoma ein sehr lustiger, ich weiß nicht mehr von wem, aber als hätten sie noch ein Geheimnis, was man noch aus dem Haus bekommen müsste. Genau, irgendwas ist da doch noch. Viele unserer Grosseltern-Gen Generationen haben tatsächlich noch viele Geheimnisse. Aber das ist ein anderes Thema. Ja, und dann waren sie dann halt irgendwann, wussten sie nicht mehr was, dann sassen sie bei den Wohnzimmern und haben halt im Fernsehen rumgesappt. Also sie konnten auch nicht mehr wirklich gut gehen und sowas und waren dann halt so ein bisschen gefesselt an ihr Wohnzimmer und ein bisschen tragisch. Und dann haben sie sich einfach kurz hingeguckt und dann kamen irgendwann sehr viele Pakete immer an und wir alle haben dann immer gesagt, das könnte ich jetzt nicht mehr machen. Aber dafür hatten sie immer perfekt klein geschnittene Karotten und Tomaten. Mit dem Nicer Dicer. Mit dem Nicer Dicer, den Messer, dem Bucket, Magic Bucket, wo alles klein geschnittert wird, also alles zerschneiden. Aber ich mag, dass bei deiner Mutter und dir jetzt so eine Dynamikumkehr stattfindet, dass nicht mehr
schau keine Horrorfilme, wir müssen aufpassen, dass
er keine Porno schaut, sondern jetzt sagst du
ich hoffe, dass meine Mutter
jetzt kein QVC schaut.
Es ist wirklich interessant, wie da irgendwann so eine
Umkehr stattfindet.
Ist ja jetzt auch schon so durch
KI generierte Bilder
oder sowas, wo man jetzt auch
sich schon Angst macht um die Älteren die kriegen das nicht mehr hin, die wissen nicht mehr, was wahr ist und was falsch ist und so. Von daher finde ich, da gibt es so eine gewisse Arroganz der Jugend so gegenüber, wir müssen unsere Eltern erziehen, wir müssen aufpassen auf sie, die werden doch nur verarscht. Aber wovor genau hast du Angst, dass er der Mutter ein Bild sieht von Olaf Scholz in einem Lebkuchenhaus und sie denkt, der ist eine Hexe oder was, also was genau ist es? Ich habe so ein Bild gesehen, da ist Olaf Scholz auf einem, ich bin sicher, das ist falsch, aber es ist sein Bild, das ist ja die Wahrheit und mit Alina Baerbock zusammen sind die auf Besen durch die Nacht geflogen. Mama, das ist nicht,. Die sind vor dem Mond mit grossen Hexenhüten, sind die beiden, das haben sie in der Heute-Show gezeigt, dieses Bild. Mama, das ist mit Computern verändert, das ist kein echtes Bild, Mama. Wie? Politiker sind keine Hexen. Das wirkt aber so, als wenn, ich weiss, dass Politiker keine Hexen sind, aber ich zumindest nicht mehr gedacht habe, es gab dieses Bild, wie die beiden mit so einer grossen weissen Wolke auf der Hex-Hex stand. Da ist die heute schon ja wirklich auch knallhart. Die enthüllen da viel, ja das stimmt. Es muss dann eigentlich so eine Anti-AI-Bewegung geben, die dann wieder die Debunk-Bilder macht, wo dann klar bewiesen wird, nein, das sind keine Hexen tatsächlich. Ich zum Beispiel, dass die irgendwie mit Weihwasser abgespritzt werden und das überleben. Und dann sagst du, guck mal Mama, hier ist das Bild, wo Annalena Baerbock und Olaf Scholz Weihwasser trinken. Wenn die Hexen wären, dann würden sie ja jetzt schmelzen. Hier, guck. Das eine ist ja so eine Fantasy-Lore und das andere ist die christliche Lore. Dass Hexen auf Besen fliegen? Nee, aber dass Maiwasser Hexen tötet, das weiß ich nicht. Aber sind Hexen nicht immer, naja, nicht immer christlich, aber schon so mit dem Besen und so? Ich glaube, da ist schon viel Besen. Oder? Der Teufel ist der Hausmeister der Hölle oder was? Also warum ist das der Besen? Vor allem stell dir vor, du verkaufst deine Seele an den Satan und dann, ja, du kannst durch die Luft fliegen. Goll! Wie? Ja, hier, nimm diesen Besen! Sorry, einen Besen? Ich dachte, ich kriege einen coolen Drachen oder einen Pegasus oder einen Greif oder einen Hypogreif oder so. Dass das bei Harry Potter niemand gesagt hat. Besen? Sorry? Ich wollte diesen Nimbus 2000 kaufen. Wo kriegt er den Nimbus 2000? Den kriegst du im Besenladen. Baumarkt. Wie im Besenladen? Ich dachte, das ist ein Fluggerät. Ja, das ist ein Fluggerät, ein Besen. Ein Besen. Ja, der Nimbus 2000, klar, der schnellste Besen, der es gibt. Sieht ja aus wie so ein Staubsaugerroboter oder was. Nein, nein, das ist ein Besen. Ja, natürlich. Wie wie sonn fliegt eigentlich auch jemand mit diesem deutschen das deutsche quidditch team ist das mit diesem rechteckigen roten mit der mit diesem plastikbos und ein die deutschen bei der quidditch meisterschaft sehr unwendig mit diesem riesen ding ja stimmt finde ich aber finde ich aber eigentlich auch gut. So, erste Unterrichtsstunde Harry Potter. Eine Frage, warum... Ja, Stuart Smiddledige. Warum fliegen wir auf Besen? Also ist es aus irgendeiner... Also, jedes Jahr gibt's diesen einen Schüler, der sich hier hinsetzt, breitestem Grinsen und sagt, warum fliegen wir eigentlich mit Besen? Jetzt bin ich gespannt. Warum telefonieren wir nicht wie die Muggel? Warum haben wir nicht riesengroße, warum haben wir riesengroße Hüte auf und nicht zum Beispiel New York Yankee Caps wie alle anderen da draußen in der echten Welt. Nun, lass dir gesagt sein, wo wäre dann der Spaß? Das ist wie ein grosses Lab Festival hier. Okay, stimmt, das war ja alles noch Quatsch. Sorry, manchmal wenn du lange in der Welt bist, denkst du, das ist echt. 20 Punkte Abzug für, woher kommst du? Offensichtlich. Raten Sie mal, Havelpuff. Aber ich denke mir, ich glaube, die ursprüngliche Idee von Hexenbesen war ja, dass man es tarnen kann, dass die jetzt nicht irgendwie so ein Fluggerät haben mit zu flügeln und dann kommt die Inquisition und sagt, ja, Sie haben ja offensichtlich ein Flugzeug im Garten stehen, Frau Müller. Sollen wir das direkt zum Schalterhaufen umbauen oder wie stellen Sie sich das vor? Ja, okay, nehmen Sie mich fest. Okay, ja, okay, sorry, aber mir macht es auch keinen Spaß, wenn es so leicht ist. Nee, super einfach. Ja, sorry, das ist aber einfach Quatsch. Wie soll man das Ding verstecken? Es ist 50 Kubikmeter gross. Ja, was weiß ich denn? Riesenfluggerät. 50 Kubikmeter? Wie ein Auto, was durch die Luft fliegt. 50 Kubikmeter gross. Und dann, glaube ich, war die Idee, ja, man kann es gut verstecken. Aber bei Harry Potter haben diese Besen ja so wirklich so Steigbügel und so einen krassen Look. Ich stelle mir einfach vor, wie Harry als Muggel also vom Weg vom Bahnhof erwischt wird, von Bullies und er hat diesen Superbesen und das ist nur ein Besen und versucht damit so zu kehren, das ist einfach so ein Ultra-Hardcore-Hochglanz-Besen einfach so, nein, das ist nur ein Besen. Dann nehmen die ihm den Besen weg, die Rüpe. Ja, jetzt jedenfalls denke ich mir, ich will so eine Bettdecke, die ich verknoten kann. Ja, ja. So, und nicht nur das, was nicht daran toll war, dass sie nicht intrinsisch verrutscht, sondern dass sie auch so gross war. Die war zwei sechzig, ich hab die auch ausgemessen dann. Ich liebe die Lappen, ich liebe Lappen. Die war zwei se zwei Vierzehzig. Ich verstehe gar nicht, warum du dich jetzt so über mich lustig machst. Warum man nicht schlafen konnte früher, weil morgen Weihnachten ist, heute, weil ich die Bettdecke so interessant fand, weil die nicht verrutscht ist. Weil ich zu gut schlafe. Weil ich weiß, dass ich zu gut schlafen werde. Ja. Und ich will wissen, warum ich so gut schlafen kann. Schlafen gehaben werde. Bei mir ist es aber andersrum. Wenn ich wirklich, wenn Not am Mann ist, dann schlafe ich eher nur mit dem Bettbezug. Das heißt, glaube ich, wir könnten uns eine Hausauflösung perfekt teilen. Du kriegst die Bettdecken, ich krieg die Bettbezug. Ich benutze keine Gabeln. Ich benutze nur Messer. Ich benutze keine Löffel. Ah, super. Ja, guck mal. Nee, Moment. Perfekt. Jetzt haben wir so ein Dreiecksding am Laufen. Da brauchen wir doch jemanden, der keine Messer benutzt. Ja. Oder der nur Gabeln benutzt. Nee, du hast keine Löffel. Nee, der könnte ja alle seine Messer durch zwei Teilen und uns die Hälfte dann jeweils geben, von dem, was man nicht braucht. Ja, ich mag Türen, du magst Händen. Ich mag Stühle. Ah. Ja, nee, komm. Naja, okay. Ja, ja. Lieben Bruce. Ja, aber wenn es wirklich heiß wird, aber manche auch habe ich für mich jetzt entdeckt, wirklich so riesige Lappen, so riesige Lappenbettdecken finde ich ganz fantastisch. Ich verstehe es nur wirklich nicht, weil man kann ja das Bettfutter, also die Bettdecke kann man ja waschen, die ist so dünn inzwischen. Ich glaube, die soll man nicht so oft waschen, weil da sind Federn drin, weißt du, die Bettbezug ist einfach nur Stoff, das kannst du waschen so oft so dünn inzwischen kann die einfach nicht so oft waschen weil da sind federn drin weißt du die bett bezug ist einfach nur stoff das ganze waschen so oft willst aber die bettdecke selber da sind federn da ist watte drin da sind irgendwie so styropor knöllchen marshmallow papp da sind so streifen von so geschredderten dokumenten drin niemand weiss genau was da drin ist wie kann es eigentlich sein dass genau wie diese dinger die bei dingen dabei liegen dass mich spezifizieren diese styroporhörnchen diese kleinen tütchen die feuchtigkeit rausziehen aus whatever in koffern hat man das drin wenn man pakete bekommt ist es da drin so kleine wo immer draufsteht do not fucking eat this you'll die first thing als wäre giftigste der Welt. Oder als wäre es das leckerste der Welt, wo man explizit draufschreiben muss, ist es auf gar keinen Fall. Verstehe ich aber. Im Gegensatz zu allem anderen. Wenn ich aufpacke und es sind so Styropornudeln drin, ich schmatze die weg, als gäbe es keinen Morgen. Ich denke mir, bei so vielen Dingen immer würde ich gerne essen, deswegen verstehe ich schon die Wahrne. Das stimmt schon, ja. Aber so. Kerzen. Ja. Oh, Kerzen denke ich mir immer so. Oh, das ist Wachs, das ist so eine geile konsistenz das hast du doch sonst nicht wandfarbe benzin wie gut benzin riecht willst du nicht mal kurz ein kleiner reinhalten ja so dippen nur mal ganz kurz was was soll passieren ich mein wenn sie haben es alle schon gerochen und genossen aber noch niemand hat es geschleckt Ich. Ich habe es vielleicht geschleckt. Benzin nicht irgendwie so 10.000 Kalorien pro 100 Milliliter oder so? Ja. Kann man sich davon ernähren? Ich weiß es nicht genau. Sehr ungesund. Es ist extrem ungesund. Nee, aber ich finde es so lustig, dass... So eine Diät, so, ja, Herr Doktor, was kann ich denn machen, um abzunehmen? Naja, Sie wissen schon, dass Benzin eine Menge Kalorien hat.
Was? Wirklich?
Niemand überrascht, was gesundes
und ungesundes Essen ist.
Der Doktor kann einfach sagen, hören Sie auf,
das zu essen, was lecker ist.
Ah, okay.
Warum mögen wir
das, was uns
tötet?
Warum mögen wir was uns... Möchte ich einfach mal so stehen lassen. Möchte ich stehen lassen. Ich auch eigentlich. Und warum tötet uns das, was wir mögen? Warum mögen wir, was uns unglücklich macht? So heißt die Folge. Und ich mag dieses sehr simple Wort mögen. Warum mögen wir das, was uns unglücklich macht?
Ja, es klingt wie ein schlechter Philosophie-Selbsthilfe-Band. So ganz unangenehm. Ja.
Ich möchte kurz einmal sagen, ich verstehe es nicht, dass wir nicht weiter sind. Und als das einzige, was diese Behältnisse trocken hält oder die Feuchtigkeit rauszieht, was ich eh nicht für einen sehr wichtigen Job halte, sorry, ist halt so ein ultra giftiges Zeug, wo man drauf schreibt, auf gar keinen Fall essen, Babys. Vor allem, das finde ich so weird, warum macht man da nicht was, und da hat eine Firma manchmal so ein Kunstobjekt draus gemacht, das ist aus Zucker, also Zuckerkügelchen, die man sehr wohl essen kann, die auch gut schmecken, den gleichen Job erfüllen. Das verstehe ich nicht, warum die nicht überall drin sind. Überall so Dinge, die man essen kann, aber die auch noch einen anderen Zweck erfüllen. Aber hat die Dinge auch schon mal jemand auf die Probe gestellt? Oder sind die einfach nur Blender? Also hat jemand wirklich schon mal Wasser versprüht? Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass die nix können und die alle nur so.
Wo ist da nichts?
Wenn da jetzt wirklich, hey, ich weiss, du bist neu hier, ich wollte es nochmal sagen, wenn wirklich hier mal was feucht ist, wir können nix machen.
Was, wir können nix? Wir sind nur da, um den Kunden ein Gefühl von Sicherheit und Professionell zu machen.
Aber die Schulung, die wir hatten.
Alles fake.
Blende rein?
Wir machen nix. Wir haben keines dieser Geräte, an denen du ausgebildet wurdest, wir haben den Sauger nicht, wir haben den Stopfer nicht, wir haben den Schlauch, haben wir alles nicht. Alles nicht da. Wir haben nichts hier, wir haben gar nichts. Es sind nur wir beide. Wie wir beide? Wir sind nur wir beide hier drin. Wenn was passiert, wenn es feucht ist, null. Wir sind auch nicht giftig? Wir sind gar nichts. Warum sind wir drin? Wir sind nichts. Warum werden wir produziert? Ja, weil die Leute wollen, dass man das Gefühl hat, oh, das ist super trocken und dass da irgendwas wertvolles ist. Wenn du das Gefühl hast, oh, das darf auf gar keinen Fall nass werden, dann denkst du dir sofort, oh, das muss was Tolles sein, so ein neues Handy oder irgendwie so Nudeln oder Kabel oder so. Wir sind nur Dinko, wir sind Fake. Wir sind ein wertsteigendes etwasigendes etwas das leute suggeriert als wäre es wichtiges verpackt ja wir sind wie so ein grünes blatt auf dem essen so das ist keiner mit so das ist niemand weiß was das ist genau so was zum beispiel das sind wir wir sind quasi nichts ich glaube du hast es schon verstanden, was wir sind. Die Goldschale von einem Ferrero. Genau, ja. Im Grunde kann man genau das sagen. Wir sind wie die Chromfelgen einem teuren Auto. Ja, na gut, da kannst du natürlich gucken, da wird halt schon der Lack ein bisschen. Wir sind die Verpackung von einem Fidschi-Wasser. Wir sind das Versprechen, das die Konsumgesellschaft dem Kunden macht. Wir sind das Hinterletzte. Wir sind der Mehrwert, der erwirtschaftet wird, wenn man die Produktkosten vom Kaufpreis abzieht. Wir sind Gewinn. Wir sind das, was übrig bleibt. Wir sind eigentlich das Produkt, wir sind eigentlich das produkt wir sind eigentlich alles
wir sind es eigentlich wir machen das produkt eigentlich ja das produkt selber ist ja nichts nein wir machen es zu was besonderer genau das iphone kann gar nicht ja das kann überhaupt nicht mit uns denken die leute an iphone warum darf es nicht nass werden wir sind der rücken der Gesellschaft. Ja, und jetzt geht er raus und macht gar nichts. Yes! Yes! Auf geht's! Unter Tausende und Abertausende. Interpretiert diesen Sketch. Ich wär so gern mal Teil einer Abi-Prüfung, oder? Ich hab sie jetzt gelesen. Ja, stimmt! Ich war jetzt und werde jetzt. Ja, Stefan Tietze hat mittlerweile das Alter erreicht, indem man seine Abiturprüfung einfordern kann. Stefan möchte noch mal nachrechnen. Hast du sie da? Können wir uns über sie lustig machen? Erschreckend, ne? Also, ich hab 2013 Abi gemacht, ich hab jetzt seit zehn Jahren Abi. Ein Jahr nach dem Abi hab ich mit dir angefangen, diesen Podcast zu machen. Wow. Das heißt, uns gibt es nächstes Jahr zehn Jahre. Das ist alles erschreckend.
Das ist schon krass.
Ich konnte jedenfalls meine Abi-Prüfungen einsehen. Es waren alle sehr genervt an der Schule.
Aber we got a man on the inside. Man kennt ja inzwischen auch die Lehrer, das ist das Problem.
Also einer aus dem Jahrgang über uns, den wir gut kennen, ist inzwischen einfach Lehrer an dieser Schule.
Ah ja. einfach Lehrer an dieser Schule. Ich habe jetzt zum ersten Mal geschnallt, es kam auch jetzt zum Nachtreffen kam Lehrer,
dass die Referendare, die damals neu kamen mit uns, eigentlich so die
coolsten Lehrer ja dann auch immer, die neuen
Referendare, die so am Start sind,
dass die damals so alt waren
wie wir jetzt, ist so
unglaublich gruselig.
Wie alt wir sind, das zeigt
einem wirklich, wie alt man diese Menschen damals
wahrgenommen hat.
Andere Sphären, in denen die stehen. Ja, ja, die wissen alles. Und in denen bin ich jetzt auch, also weise ich jetzt per se alles. Naja, dann habe ich die Abiprüfung eingelesen und ja spannend, ich hatte ja Deutsch, LK, Mathe LK, Mathe LK habe ich nicht so richtig verstanden, was ich da. Ja, du hast ja versucht, die Riemann-Hypothese zu lösen, noch in der Abi-Arbeit, du hast ja da wirklich viele Diagramme gemacht. Und man weiss nicht, ob du es geschafft hast, das konnte niemand in den Zimmer. Nee, also das ist die Brüder aber nicht so richtig verstanden. Und ich habe sehr, sehr ausführlich mit einem Kumpel, der auch Deutsch-LK hatte, unsere Deutsch-LK-Briefung gelesen, wo wir Buddenburgs vergleichen mussten mit Tauben im Gras, zwei Textausschnitte vergleichen mussten.
Das war super interessant, während mein Kumpel, der jetzt auch Texter ist, inzwischen wirklich wunderbar geschrieben hat, wirklich wunderschöne Prosa, aber nicht so viele Punkte bekommen hat, weil ich einfach mit meinem pragmatischen Ticking all the boxes, jetzt mache ich das, jetzt mache ich das, folgende drei Gründe, relativ pragmatisch war. Also ich habe ein paar Sachen, war dann auch schön, aber sonst sehr pragmatisch runtergerockt. Ja, relativ langlos. Kannst du was vorlesen, hast du was da? Ich habe es jetzt nicht dabei, kann ich nächste Woche mitbringen, wenn es Leute interessiert. Ich wollte mal, ich weiß nicht, ob das so cool ist. Naja, die Tauben im Gras, das ist natürlich, ich glaube, das würde schon viel interessieren. Was ist der Unterschied? Sind das überhaupt zwei unterschiedliche Texte? Und dann, was dich sehr interessieren wird, ist dann meine Philosophieprüfung und da kann ich nächste Woche mal was daraus vorlesen, weil die Philosophieprüfung, die hatte ich auch schriftlich, da musste ich, da ging es um den Empirismus, Wahrnehmungsfragen. Also wie nehmen wir die Welt wahr? Und da gab es einen ganz spannenden Text, der nämlich die Theorie hatte, dass man, wenn man einen von einem Kind gezeichneten Kreis betrachtet, also einen krakeligen, schlecht gemalten Kreis, denken wir nicht, ah, das ist ein und geben dem ein neues Wort oder so oder denken da an abstrakte Form, sondern wir denken ans Vollkommene, an den Kreis und schliessen dann von dem Kreis auf den abstrakteren Kreis, den wir da sehen. Das heißt, und da denken wir in gewisser Weise in Sprache. Und das ist ja ganz spannend, weil ist Sprache demnach einfach der Weg, wie wir die Welt wahrnehmen? Und was auch immer. Und dann ist der letzte Satz Glauben Sie, dass die Inuit den Schnee genauso wahrnehmen wie wir, obwohl sie 50 Wörter dafür haben? Und das war der letzte Satz dieser Prüfung. Und man denkt sich, holy shit, du bist 17 Jahre alt, chill, chill. Davor habe ich noch versucht Platon, weil dann musste man das vergleichen mit Platons Höhlen-Gleichnis und habe Platon auseinandergenommen. Ich habe keine Fehler an dem gelassen, der war durch am Ende. Ich habe im Prinzip Platon, ich habe ihn noch als arroganten Wichser beschimpft, also ich habe ihn wirklich zerlegt. Ich wollte Platon widerlegen. Die Bankt. Ich habe mir wirklich in diesen vier Stunden, die man da Zeit hatte für diese Prüfung, überlegt, nee, ich widerlege jetzt Platon. Super der Inbegriff der Arroganze, diese Prüfung, aber Platon hat schon so Schweiß auf der Stirn, zittert, weiss es auch nicht mehr genau, was er sagen soll und Stefan Tietze einfach ballert ein Argument nach dem anderen. Ja, nimm mal ein Stabilo. Ich nehme ein Stabilo in die Hand und mal dir deine Widerlegung in meiner Abiprüfung. Wahnsinn. Also das war super spannend. Vielleicht kann ich was vorlesen. Ich finde das Thema super interessant, tatsächlich. Und dann bin ich auch in der Prüfung auf, wie ich finde, eine ganz gute Idee gekommen, dass man Dinge auch abstrakter wahrnehmen kann und das trotzdem zum gleichen Ergebnis führen würde. Also zum Beispiel habe ich dann geschrieben von, wenn es ein Mensch bei Tieren aufwächst, unsere Sprache nicht kennt, unsere Möbel nicht kennt, unsere Dinge nicht kennt und dann trifft er auf eine Gruppe Menschen und Stühle. Kann es gut sein, dass er sich trotzdem draufsetzen wird auf den Stuhl? Nicht, weil er zuerst denkt an das Wort Stuhl und dann darauf schliesst, ah, ich kann mich draufsetzen, was ist ein Stuhl, das Gelegenheit, blablabla, sondern er setzt sich einfach hin, weil es eine gute Form hat, weil es dafür gemacht ist, sich hinzusetzen, weil er das kennt, weil er sitzen kennt und er würde es vielleicht genau gleich benutzen, diesen Stuhl, ohne zuerst an das Vollkommene zu denken oder wie auch immer. Kein anderer Stuhl, also, sondern es ist eine Sitzgelegenheit, es passt. Da merkt man aber, dass du ein wahrer Philosoph bist, denn du hast in deinem Gedankenexperiment den Stuhl mit reingenommen. Und ich glaube, es ist immer so, wenn es irgendwelche Gedankenexperimente gibt, es ist immer der Stuhl. Wir betrachten einen Stuhl und du siehst ihn auch leicht aus einer anderen perspektive und wenn ich um den stuhl rumgehe habe ich ja jedes mal einen anderen stuhl gesehen aber es ist immer noch ein objekt und so es sind immer stühle ich glaube wenn irgendwann mal die aliens alle unsere philosophie nachholen denken sich was haben was haben die denn mit diesen scheiss stühlen ja klar mein gott setz dich drauf und gut ist ich mag das andere alien ich mag stühle auch ich wundere mich warum bei uns immer tische gesprochen werden. Ja, klar. Mein Gott, setz dich drauf und gut ist. Ne, ich mag, was sagt das andere Alien? Ne, ich mag Stühle auch. Ich wundere mich, warum bei uns immer Tische gesprochen werden. Ja genau, Tische sind auch immer Tisch und Stuhl, aber da merkt man so diese Philosophen, diese genialen Genies ihrer Zeit, Kant, Hegel, aber denen fällt nichts besseres ein, als nur man denke an einen Stuhl. Stuhl. Oh, ich auch. Wow. Einfach immer Stuhl, aber da merkt man schon, du hast das Zeug zum großen Philosophen. Du hast das Beispiel, wenn du in einem Dschungel Leuten begegnest, die haben Stühle dabei. Ne, ne, ne, ne. Und du hast noch nie Menschen kennengelernt. Ne, wenn er bei Tieren auch so ein Murgelcharakter, wenn der in die Zivilisation käme. Und das erste, was du siehst, sind Stühle. Zum Beispiel. Menschen, die halt mit ihren Stühlen, was Menschen halt so machen. Ja, wenn du jetzt bei den Gedankenexperimenten noch auf Wahrheit und Realismus gehst, dann haben wir einen Rott. Ja, dann kriegst du eine Sechs. Wenn du im Philosophieabitur sagst, also das Gedankenexperiment ist ja wirklich völlig unrealistisch, weil die würden ja nicht einen Stuhl mitbringen. Und mein Kumpel hat Englisch LK und das ist ja wirklich the pinnacle im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Was heißt das? Of cringe, cringiness. Oh, okay. Also wenn man da ja auch, man schreibt ja so, als würde man die Sprache, als würde man da träumen, als wäre das wirklich, wenn man ein native speaker. Man hat aber sehr. Ja, man hat dieses übertriebene englischen Akzent auch. Man hat auch diese Formen gelernt, wie man dann das analysieren soll, so in the following, I may analyze, the whole body of work, if you would be so kind to allow me a quick analysis, I ihn zu lesen. Das ist die eigentliche Entwicklung dieses Menschen, sag ich jetzt mal. Ohne Stand hinten, unter der Klausur, sein Name, Komma, Carmen, 2013, Germany. Dreimal unterstrichen. Und wir dachten uns, wow. Dann haben wir gesehen, er muss einen Brief schreiben. Weil ich verstehe es ein bisschen, aber wir haben kurz gedacht, okay, wir beide haben einfach den Verstand verloren, kurz.
Ich glaube, das mache ich jetzt bei jeder E-Mail. Florentin Will, Komma, Köln, Komma, Deutschland. Ja, Deutschland. Florentin Will 2023. Des Herrn, Anno Domini 2023. Ja, und er hat, musste einen Brief an New York Times oder so was schreiben, ging um so einen Gen-Manipulations-Artikel. Es ist so krass, wie viele Kinder mit Pränataldiagnostik und Abtreibung zu tun haben. Die gehen in die Welt und denken, darum geht es den ganzen Tag. Es wird nur über Pränataldiagnostik und Abtreibung diskutiert und die haben alle Argumente, haben alles, wirklich, die sind bereit und dann so, ja, welcher der Ring ist dein Lieblingsfilm? Und so, völlig blank, völlig blank. Wir können stundenlang über Pränataldiagnostik diskutieren. Ab welcher Woche, was, wie darf man sich Eigenschaften des Kindes aussuchen, blablabla, kann ich ja alles runtergehen. Designer-Babys. Designer-Baby, Fragezeichen, ja. Philosophie auch bei uns ständig Designer-Babys Thema gewesen. Es war mir zu, es war mir zu, wollte ich nicht, war mir zu oft benutzt, diese Diskussion. Nee, es ging aber um Gentechnik und Tiere, Massentierhalte, bla bla bla. Und da hat er dann geschrieben, I as an activist, as an environmental activist, just want to say. Und irgendwas, aber es war ihm so unangenehm. Ich als Sätze sind das Schlimmste, was man sagen kann. Egal in welcher Sprache, wenn du dich in irgendeiner Weise selber beschreibst, bist du immer schon direkt aus. Dann kann ich als und egal was dann ankommen, kann man ersetzen durch Vollidiot. Egal was da steht, kann man im Kopf direkt ersetzen. Ich als Sätze sind die grösste Red Flag, sehr, sehr erkennbare Red Flag in sozialen Interessen. Ich bin ja auch ein bisschen ... und kompletter vollidiot genau auch sind genauso das kann ich alles aber ich charakterisierende ich setze holy shit ja ich bin auch ein bisschen verrückt hier meine medias wir trinken ab und zu ein bisschen was wir sind ja ja ja das war schon-Date. Wir haben noch fünfeinhalb Liter kochend heißen Tee. Ja, das passiert mir ständig. Bestellt keine Tee. Diese All-You-Can-Drink-Tee-Häuser immer furchtbar. Bottomless-Tee. Nee, reicht, reicht! Kein Tee mehr. Deswegen, ja, sucht euch die Restaurants aus mit den kleinsten Portionen für Dates, das ist ja auch mal die kleine Tassen. Ja genau, so fünf Minuten kann man wieder direkt gehen, aber ich glaube, also ist nicht, also das normale Dates ist ja eigentlich eher abends, ne? Ja, sehe ich auch so. Wobei ich mittlerweile sagen würde, nach zehn bin ich wirklich raus. Also ich war, wenn, wenn noch mal, wenn es ums Daten ginge, ich glaube, ich wäre so, hey, du bist so Rocco von Tinder. Ja. Ja, sorry. Ah ja, du bist, du bist die Clara. Bist du müde oder so? Sorry, es ist war ein schöner Tag. Nee, es ist halb es ist halb zehn, ich würde sagen, wir machen jetzt wir machen so zwanzig Minuten und dann würde ich es packen. Ehrlich gesagt finde ich das total perfekt. Ich finde das so gut. In einem gewissen Alter hast du einfach nicht mehr die Kraft, irgendwie nach zehn noch noch wach zu sein. Dates sind so spannend. Also wirklich, man hat dann so wenig Lust an dem, wenn es konkret wird, sich zu treffen. Hattest du jemals Lust, wenn es dann konkret wurde, an dem jeweiligen Tag, dich dann anzuziehen, so noch ein Parfum aufzulegen, dich, Jesus fucking Christ, ist das die absolute Hölle? Vor allem das Dumme ist, wenn der State am Abend ist, ist der ganze Tag erledigt. Im Arsch. Du kannst nicht sagen, ach jetzt schaue ich, jetzt lese ich nochmal die Tauben im Gras entspannt. So, vergiss es. Mach doch Date, 12.30 Uhr, zack, Drive-in, wunderbar, 20 Minuten auf dem Parkplatz, Ende. Ich bin für, also erstes Date, sind wir uns da einig, ist ein Abklopfen, ist ein emotionales Mindset Abklopfen, wo ist man, so passt man überhaupt zusammen, führt das irgendwo hin, mehr, also es ist so, gucken wie sehr klickt man, kriegt man uns verbunden als Menschen und es ist so dieses Abklopfen, so eine Anamnese, mal so ein Formular ausfüllen. Genau. So, politische Ansicht. Okay. Haben wir uns da. Humor? Ist vorhanden. Gut, alles klar. Ist vorhanden. Ist vorhanden. Alles klar, haben wir... Irgendwie, wie wir der Ex-Freunde? Wie wir der Ex-Freunde? Ne, bis dann. Nein, alles klar. Bislang noch nie. Kannst du bei Humor vielleicht noch ein Sternchen dran? Humor würde ich noch mal anhaken, ja. Mach mal auf eine Zwei. Zwei? Okay. Alles klar. Nervig laute Lache? Nee, eher, ja, also das wäre das eigentlich. Aber das ist ja nicht das Maximum. Doch, also ich lache nicht so laut und nicht so viel.
Okay.
So vielleicht noch.
Nicht so laut.
Alles klar, Wohnsituation?
Zuuu!
Okay, ich glaube, wir können die nächsten Seiten überspringen, dann bräuchte ich einmal hier eine Unterschrift und dann haben wir es. Selbstverständlich, danke schön. Danke, ja. Oh, du hast dir auch in Kontakt gehabt mit dem Kellner? Jetzt in dem Moment, wenn man es braucht. Wahnsinn. Ja, also ehrlich gesagt, deswegen muss es nicht unbedingt abends stattfinden. Ehrlich gesagt, ich mag meinen, und Finger weg von Freitagen, Samstagen und Sonntagen bei ersten Dates, Finger weg, Leute, es sei euch sehr sicher. Ja, schönen Mittwoch, schönen Dienstag, schönen Donnerstag. Diese mittleren Tage, die merke ich da sehr.
Und dann schreckt nicht zurück für einen frühen Abend.
Frühen Abend, da hätte ich aber Angst. Und dann schreckt nicht zurück für ein früher Abend.
Früher Abend, da hätte ich aber Angst, dass man dann viel Zeit füllen muss. Muss man nicht, muss man nicht. Deswegen, du kannst ja schreiben so. Er findet immer einen Anschlusstermin. Ja, aber schon von Anfang an, hey, lass uns mal 15 Uhr sagen, ich muss so ab 17 Uhr oder so muss ich nochmal gucken, weil ich passe auf die Katze von einem Kumpel auf. und also ich habe ein bisschen Spielraum, je nachdem, aber vielleicht muss ich auch ganz früh, also vielleicht muss ich auch sofort. Also je nachdem, wie das Date läuft, muss ich entweder schon sehr früh aufpassen. Je nachdem, wie gut wir uns verstehen, muss ich früher oder später mal die Katze meines Kumpels. Je nachdem, wie sehr ich dich mag und mit dir schlafen will, würde ich halt eher... Würde ich die erfundene Katze meines Kumpels füttern, würde ich... Ke kein Problem, kein Problem. Je nachdem, wie es mir mit dir geht, muss ich nur auf den Geburtstag meiner Freundin, die nicht Geburtstag hat und was rein ausgedacht ist oder eben nicht. Die um 16 Uhr feiert, die um 16 Uhr feiert. Okay, alles klar, gut. Die um 16 Uhr auf dem Dienstag feiert. Okay, wir mögen beide ausreden, alles klar, das ist doch schon mal. Ja, aber so ist es doch. Und deswegen ist das W ja auch alle, und das ist doch okay. Habe ich letztens auf Reddit gelesen, da gibt es eine App, die explizit für Absager gedacht ist. Ich liebe es ja, Termine abzusagen. Und da ist die Idee, du kannst dich bei der App anmelden und angenommen, wir haben uns jetzt verabredet. Auftragskiller engagieren. Ja, einfach die andere Person umbringen. Ja. Und wir haben uns jetzt verabredet, schön, wir wollen schön ins Kino, wir wollen den neuen Film sehen, hier den ... Das Schweigen des Atems. Das Schweigen des Atems, genau. Und dann kann ich bei meiner App ... Zwei. Bei meiner App sagen, sage ich ab. Und wenn du dann auch sagst, sage ich ab, dann sehen wir beide, matchen wir. Oh mein Gott! Und dann haben wir beide abgesagt und dann lassen wir es einfach ausfallen, ohne dass man dem anderen sagen muss, ich würde es gerne ausfallen lassen, man bietet es einfach an und ich würde mir denken, ich würde jeden einzelnen Termin immer absagen. Aber für mich soziales Chamäleon gehen da jetzt alle Türen auf gerade. Holy Shit, das will ich mit allen Dingen haben.
Ja, ich habe schon mal Hunger angeklickt und wenn du auch Hunger anklickst, ja, können wir was essen gehen? Ja, okay. Aber ich will es nicht sagen. Ich will nicht derjenige sein, der sagt, können wir was essen gehen?
Es ist dieses Matching-Prinzip, so du kannst genau gucken, du siehst es erst, wenn beide das gleiche haben.
Hast du gerade den Sex-Falter aktiviert bei dir?
Achso, ich wollte ja nur mal gucken.
Hä, wir sind da zehn Minuten hängen gehabt. Ach so, ne, ne. Ah, ist er aus. Jetzt ist er weggekommen. Ne. Da, ja? Ne, das ist ja spannend. Weil das kannst du ja mit allen Dingen, also das muss ja nicht nur eine Ausrede-App sein, sondern eine, wir nennen sie mal, ist jetzt unsere App, das Podcast-UFO? Okay, alles klar. die Sync-App. Wir synchronisieren uns. Die Ach du auch-App. Ja genau, ach du auch schon Lust auf. Und dann kann man eingeben, zum Beispiel kann man bei Sex einen Haken setzen. Und dann siehst du, ob sie es auch wird. Ich glaube, das grosse Problem ist halt das alte Tinder-Problem, dass irgendwann, also bei Tinder, wenn man einfach alles swiped und dann einfach nur guckt, was bleibt hängen. Genauso glaube ich, kreuzt du auch einfach alles an bei der App und guckst halt, was bleibt hängen bei der anderen Person, die das gleiche macht und dann hast du dich für eine mehrjährige Beziehung mit Kindern direkt committed, obwohl du einfach mal nur so einen Ja-mal-Gucken-Haken gesetzt hast und dann bist du irgendwo in einer Ehe drin, aus der du nicht mehr rauskommst und hast ein richtiges Problem. Das liebe ich ja bei Tinder, wenn da steht ja mal gucken und feste Beziehung. Ja, willst du wirklich gucken? Ist das das, was du willst? Mal gucken, das was du willst, wenn du auch feste Beziehung als Haken gesetzt hast. Sollte nicht zusammen funktionieren. Ja, aber das finde ich ja spannend. Das Problem ist, beide brauchen diese App, wie ich die jetzt rein technisch verstehe. Und eigentlich muss jeder diese App schon besitzen, weil du willst ja nicht sagen, hey Stefan, hättest du Bock, morgen mit mir ins Kino zu gehen? Ja, muss ich mir. Und ich habe noch eine App-Idee. Ich würde dir gerne noch eine App empfehlen. Absagen. Genau, absagen die App. Ich will absagen. Ich will eigentlich nicht die App. Die kann ich dir auch empfehlen. Wieso muss ich die haben? Willst du absagen? Nein, nein, nein, nein, Quatsch, überhaupt nicht. Willst du das nicht absagen? Nein, ich liebe das Schweigen der Stimme. Ich wollte es unbedingt... Das Atem. Entschuldigung. Das klingt so, als würdest du gar nicht interessieren für den Film. Doch, ich liebe den Film. Ich mochte den ersten schon richtig gerne. Hast du den gesehen? Ich habe Poster gesehen und einen Trailer und dann kann man sich ja oft schon viel... Dann kann man eingeben mit der App, ich lüge gerade. Und wenn der andere das auch macht, dann... Lüge auch gerade. Dann kürzt sich's wieder raus quasi. Ich lüge immer. Kürzt sich weg. Es kürzt sich weg, so heißt die App. Apostroph, es kürzt sich weg. Ja, such das mal schön im App Store mit einem Apostroph als erstes. Aber es ist vielleicht immer die oberste App. Es ist vielleicht immer die oberste App in der alphabetischen Liste. Oder das letzte mit Apostroph. Wir wissen auch nicht genau richtig. Das finde ich ja genial. Ist eine gute Idee. So eine Sync-App. Braucht halt wirklich, jeder Mensch müsste das eigentlich schon haben, so auf dem Handy. dass wenn du es runterlädst dass es schon hast also wenn du keine ahnung du hast ein jugendliches kind und sagst jetzt ist zeit dass es ein handy hat und dann würde ich als verantwortungsvolles elternteil schon gewisse apps installieren unter anderem es ist ja ich kürze sich weg es kürze sich weg eine podcast ufo-appproduktion es kürzt sich weg, es kürzt sich weg, eine Podcast-UFO-App-Produktion, es kürzt sich ja eh raus. Es kürzt sich halt raus. Dann hast du hier, hast du Castle Run, Train Jump und es kürzt sich ja eh raus. Das sind die vorinstallierten Apps, dann kannst du eine schon mit einstellen. Ja, finde ich super. Ich habe gestern gehört, drittes Date und dann haben die zusammen, das hat mich wahnsinnig gestresst, diese Vorstellung, haben die zusammen Sex Education, also eine Serie geguckt.
nicht nur stresst mich diese konkrete serie beim date zu gucken wo es ja um viel um sex geht und offene kommunikation und so wahnsinnig muss man sich schon sehr
muss man sich selbstbewusst sein finde ich um die Themen, die da verhandelt werden, in der Beziehung auch alle offen zu legen. Es ist ja so der Klassiker peinlich Sex-Szenen mit den Eltern, aber mit dem Partner-Sex-Szenen ist auch nicht immer. Oder auf dem Date. Ja, magst du das? Das haben wir noch nie gemacht. Bei Sex-Education, wo es darum geht, Frauen stecken den Männern Finger in den Arsch, das will man vielleicht nicht verhandeln. Beim dritten Date und nicht nur, dass ich finde, auch eine Serie zu gucken beim dritten Date, wahnsinnig alltäglich. Es ist schon ein Commitment. Voll, es ist so ein alltägliches Ding, finde ich, mit Partner, Partnerin, einen Film oder eine Serie zu gucken.
Vor allem, du musst schon wirklich viel Vertrauen in die Serie haben, weil die ersten Dates haust du dein bestes Material raus. Das ist einfach so, da ist noch die A-Klasse, da hast du noch die AA-Anekdoten, die B-Plus vielleicht noch haust du raus. Und da eine Serie zu haben, wo du sagst, okay, ich meine, da würde man dann wahrscheinlich lügen und eine nehmen, die man schon gesehen hat, oder? Wo man weiss, die ist richtig gut. Wo man die Funfacts dazu hat. Und dann haben beide... Und dann haben beide schon die Serie gesehen und tun beide so, als hätten sie nicht gesehen, bis sie in ihrer App merken, oh, der hat Breaking Bad alle 19 Staffeln schon gesehen. Lügt, lügt gerade wieder. Nee, ich we wieder. Nee, ich weiß nicht, ich finde das so ein alltägliches, das kann man doch machen, wenn man zusammen ist dann. Aber so beim Date, also erzählt euch doch was oder so. Aber irgendwie, ich finde das fast, ich finde, und das ist natürlich auch stressend, aber ich finde es viel stressiger die Vorstellung, dass man dann schon so ein Pärchen spielt beim dritten Date und dann zusammen eine Serie kult. Ja, fand ich. Komm doch auf die Serien. Ich glaube, da gibt es gute und schlechtere Serien. Da muss man schon gut treffen. Serien ist echt schwer, da genau zu treffen. Das schafft man ja teilweise nicht, wenn man sich richtig gut kennt, Serien zu finden, wo man sagt, da haben jetzt beide gleichermaßen Bock drauf und es ist nicht so, einer zieht mit. Florentin Serientipps. Hey Leute, herzlich willkommen bei Florentin Serientipps. Florentin Serientipps. Ich weiß, das erste Mal heute. Ich muss ein bisschen, ups, Vorsicht, Entschuldigung, okay, los geht's. Also ich habe heute für euch. Das waren Florentin Serientipps. Also es gibt schon ein paar gute Serien, die man dafür benutzen kann.
Ja, vielleicht schaut doch einfach nächste Woche mal ein paar coole Serien-Tipps.
Ja, aber auch mal gerne alleine, schön im Bett.
Und auch mal gerne, traut euch Serien abzubrechen.
Traut euch Serien abzubrechen, einfach.
Voll, finde ich auch. Das Zeit ist vorbei.
Weg damit.
Und hört auf in englischen E-Mails.
Vielleicht muss ich in der englischen E-Mail, mag ich das nicht, dieses nice to meet you. Auch im Deutschen nicht. Schön, dich kennenzulernen. Mehr komisch, in einer E-Mail, wo man connected wird, wo man verbunden wird. Finde ich das total unheimlich zu sagen, schön, dich kennenzulernen. Ja, wie? Also, aber das ist vorbei. Das habe ich dann gegoogelt, nämlich, wie schreibt man auf Englisch, das ist cool. Da hat mal jemand zu mir geschrieben, nice to e-meet you. Und da habe ich schon gegen den Wind gerochen, dass das uncool ist. Uncool.
Dann habe ich es gegoogelt und dann hat wirklich irgendwie so eine richtig coole, ich weiß nicht, ob es die Times war oder der New Yorker hat gesagt, nee, wir leben im digitalen Zeitalter, sagt nice to meet you, schreibt, schön dich kennenzulernen, auch bei Mails. Okay, man lernt sich nicht visuell kennen, nicht in Persona, aber so viel Kommunikation findet gerade digital statt, das ist völlig okay, einfach zu schreiben.
Weil ich denke mir jedes Mal, ich finde das in Mails irgendwie übergriffig zu sagen, schön dich kennenzulernen.
Du, es gibt manche Newsletter, mit denen habe ich ein besseres Verhältnis als mit echten Freunden.
Als mit mir?
Ja, als mit dir zum Beispiel. Du sagst doch immer bei mir, abbestellen, abbestellen, ausser nichts. Ja, immer wenn du mir bei WhatsApp schreibst, schreibe ich bitte abbestellen. Und ich sag immer, hä? Bitte kein Interesse. Ich ohne, ohne Angabe von Gründen abbestellen. Es ist immer so, warum möchten sie unser Newsletter abbestellen? Weil ihr mir acht Mails am Tag schickt.
Ach so, aber wir dachten, wir interessieren sich dafür.
Ich habe einmal ein Ticket bei euch gebucht, weil ich einmal in London war und jetzt schickt ihr mir achtmal am Tag.
Was denkt ihr denn, was ich für einen Mitteilungsdrang habe von euch?
Wenn ihr diesen Fragebogen macht, wenn man euren Newsletter abbestellen kann und ihr macht diesen Fragebogen und wollt dann von euch aus inkludieren den Punkt, weil sie diesen Newsletter zu häufig bekommen, dann könnt ihr schon darauf schliessen, dass ihr den wahrscheinlich zu oft rausschickt. Wenn das bei euch eine Option ist, die ihr erfragen wollt, oder kriegen sie vielleicht zu viele, ja, ja, ja, das ist eine Unsicherheit. Das ist, wie wenn jemand mit dir Schluss macht und du sagst, ist es, weil ich dir zu viele Nachrichten checke,, dann weißt du schon die Frage alleine, dann weißt du schon, wo das Problem ging. Wenn du formulierst, weil wir euch zu viele schicken, dann was vermutlich schickt ihr zu viel. Weil wir euch acht am Tag schicken mit riesigen Bildern. Ah, sind acht zu viel? Es sind acht zu viel, Moment mal acht und bei jedem ist noch ein riesiges Bild dabei, das vier Megabyte nochmal verbraucht. Achtmal am Tag, siebenmal die Woche, da ist die Festplete ganz schön voll. Ja, genau daran liegt's. Ja, genau. Ich finde dann, ja, das machen nämlich Fitnessstudios ja richtig clever, die keine Newsletter rausschicken, weil sie die Kunden nicht erinnern. Ja, das sind eigentlich die besseren Betriebe, ja, das ist richtig gut. Aber man könnte natürlich auch einstellen, dass es sich so hochtaktet, dass wenn du den abschließt, dann kriegst du eine pro Monatat und dann irgendwann zwei pro Monat und dann wirkst du den Kunden so richtig so so wie vier pro Monat und dann komm noch mal zwei pro Woche Eih, ba, be, ah, ba, be, ah, ah, ba, ah, ah, ba, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, bah. Und damit lassen wir ihn die Woche. Macht es gut. Ich kann mittlerweile nicht mehr ohne leben. Nee, ich kann auch nicht. Ich muss es immer sagen und ich freue mich, das zu sagen. Ich bin einfach, ich sag es wie so ein Ohrwurm, den man hat. Macht's gut, kommt gut durch die Woche. Einen grossen Kuss an alle Hörsinn. Stosst euch nichts vorsichtig auf Knie und Arm beugen.
Zehen, achtet auf eure Zehen.
Passt auf, Schuhe reichen oft nicht als Schutz.
Macht's gut, habt eine schöne Woche und wir sehen uns nächste Woche.
Wenn es wieder heisst.
Bis dann.
Florentins Serientipps.
It's a Worst Bird Production.